.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Schon als Kind träumten sie davon,
Tierarzt zu werden.
Wir haben drei der jungen Tierärzte
begleitet.
Gwennaëlle macht eine Spezial-
ausbildung für neue Haustiere.
Um sich weiterzubilden,
ist sie in einer Praxis in Belgien,
die auf Nagetiere, Vögel
und Reptilien spezialisiert ist.
William macht ein Volontariat
im Notfall des Berner Tierspitals.
Im hochmodernen Spital
hat er es mit kritischen und manchmal
hoffnungslosen Fällen zu tun.
Eléonore liebt Kühe und arbeitet
als Landtierärztin in Porrentruy.
Ein anstrengender Beruf.
Wie lang der Tag wird,
weiss man nie zum Voraus.
*  Lockere Musik *
Und das sind sie -
unsere jungen Tierärzte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Die Tierarztklinik Ajovet
in Porrentruy
macht sich bereit
für eine Invasion von Welpen.
Sie sind vier Wochen alt und
müssen zum ersten Mal zum Tierarzt.
* Drollige Musik *
* Winseln *
Achtung. Ja.
Eléonore ist überglücklich,
den Tag mit so Pelzkügelchen
anstatt mit Kühen zu beginnen.
Für die Besitzerin Marie
war es eine Überraschung,
dass ihre Hündin Nachwuchs erwartete.
Fürs Zügeln liess sie ihren Hund
Ilaya für ein paar Tage bei Freunden.
Sie passten nicht gut auf
und sie lief davon. Voilà.
Danach war sie schwanger.
Schätzchen.
Es sind sechs.
- Ja, sechs. Genau.
Ja, ich bin die Tierärztin.
Die Pfötchen sind schon recht gross.
Grosse Pfötchen.
Es fühlt sich nicht nach Arbeit an.
Es ist schön, kam sie
mit den sechs Pelzknäuelchen vorbei.
Man hat nicht das Gefühl
zu arbeiten.
Mit vier Wochen
müssen die Welpen entwurmt werden.
Sonst kann es Würmer im Darm geben,
die für die Tiere gefährlich
und auch auf Menschen
übertragbar sind.
Du bist ganz mutig.
Was meinst du? Hm?
Ich lasse dich nie mehr los.
Mutter Ilaya
hat alles unter Kontrolle.
Sie ist
ein Tschechoslowakischer Wolfshund.
Diese Rasse ist noch nicht so alt.
Eine Mischung aus einer
Karpatenwölfin und einem Hund.
Das Tier stammt vom Wolf ab.
Deshalb hat es immer noch
diesen nicht wilden,
aber unabhängigen Charakter.
Wenn ich mit ihr spazieren gehe,
bin ich immer relativ vorsichtig.
Sie hat
eine eindrückliche Ausstrahlung.
Und ...
Sie könnte jemandem Angst machen.
Nicht jeder
kann mit so einem Hund umgehen.
Man muss wissen, was es heisst,
so einen Hund zu haben.
Es kann etwas passieren,
er kann gefährlich werden -
wie jeder Hund,
der nicht korrekt gehalten wird.
Ja, ich halte dein Baby im Arm,
ich tue ihm nichts.
Manchmal wollen sie die Leute
auf der Strasse streicheln,
aber das bringt nichts.
Die Leute müssen den Hund
auf sich zukommen lassen.
Man sie von unten her anfassen.
Wenn eine so grosse Hand
von oben auf den Hund kommt,
könnte er schlecht reagieren,
weil er erschrickt.
Von unten her hat man etwas Angst,
weil dort die Schnauze ist.
Sie kann riechen
und es passiert nichts.
Dann kann man sie gut streicheln.
* Winseln *
Ja? Oh, oh, oh.
Sie sind recht schwer.
Wie alt sind sie?
Erst einen Monat -
und sie sind riesig.
Ja, was!
Schon 4 kg. Wie sehen sie
wohl ausgewachsen aus?
Der Vater ist unbekannt.
Sie sind megasüss,
wenn sie so klein sind.
Die hier
werden einmal richtig gross.
Die bleiben nicht so.
Das sieht man schon an den Pfoten.
Das gibt sehr grosse Hunde.
Eine ganze Truppe von Welpen.
Und die Truppe wird schon bald
in Familien platziert.
Im Jura, in der Waadt,
in Frankreich und im Wallis.
Schon mit sieben Monaten
sind Amarok, Nessa, Kiba, Djerko
Nox und Bandit zu 40 kg
schweren Brocken herangewachsen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf dem Parkplatz
des Tierspitals in Bern
wartet das Notfallteam
auf einen Berner Sennenhund.
Die fünfjährige Sina
wird in einem äusserst
kritischen Zustand eingeliefert.
Man sagte uns, der Hund sei
in einem extrem schlechten Zustand.
Er sei zu schwach zum Laufen,
deshalb mussten wir ihn holen.
So ein Hund ist nicht wie ein
Chihuahua. Er ist schwer zu tragen.
Sie ist sehr schwach und will
sich nicht von selbst bewegen.
Du bist ganz bleich.
Die Mundschleimhaut ist fast weiss -
ein gefährliches Zeichen.
Das deutet auf ein Problem
mit den roten Blutkörperchen hin.
Es steht schlecht um Sina.
Ihre inneren Organe
bekommen zu wenig Sauerstoff.
Es braucht eine Blutanalayse.
Sie ist so schwach,
weil sie eine starke Blutarmut hat.
Sie könnte in 1 Std. tot sein.
Sina ist in Lebensgefahr
und extrem schwach.
William ist sehr besorgt.
Die Untersuchung muss schnell gehen,
aber man darf nichts vergessen.
Ich denke, es bräuchte ...
... je nach Hämatokritwert
eine Transfusion.
Zwei Beutel Blut.
- Ja, zwei bis drei würde ich sagen.
Okay, dann machen wir mal
eine Transfusion und schauen weiter.
Der Hund braucht sicher
zwei Beutel Blut.
Ja, so viel.
- Der Hund ist gross.
Wir machen eine Bluttransfusion. Das
solllte ihren Zustand stabilisieren
und ihr mehr Kraft geben.
Auch Tiere haben das Recht
auf Bluttransfusionen.
Bei Hunden gibt es zwei Blutgruppen.
Sina muss natürlich
mit ihren Spendern kompatibel sein.
Wir müssen aufpassen,
dass sie das Blut gut aufnimmt
und es keine Abstossreaktion gibt.
Deshalb müssen wir gewisse
Vorsichtsmassnahmen treffen
und sie während der Transfusion
beobachten.
Es geht dir bald besser.
Die Transfusion dauert 4 Std.
Während das Blut
in die Venen fliesst,
kommt Sina langsam wieder zu Kräften.
Eine Medizinstudentin
ist den ganzen Nachmittag bei ihr.
William informiert
die leitende Notärztin Katja,
dass die Blutreserven im Spital
knapp sind.
Die, die es noch hat,
reichen nicht mehr lange.
... je ne sais pas avec ...
Also einer der beiden
geht heute Nacht noch weg.
Die bekommt einer,
der morgen operiert wird.
Dann haben wir noch drei.
Der Hund ist gross.
Vielleicht benötigt er
noch mehr Blut.
Benötigt er noch viel Blut,
reicht es nicht mehr
für viele weitere Transfusionen.
Wir müssen weitere Spender finden.
Das Spital führt eine Spenderliste.
Die Spender müssen rasch kommen.
Es geht um das Leben von Sina.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Telefonklingeln, Stimmengewirr *
Jetzt gehen wir nach Belgien,
wo Gwennaëlle in der Tierklinik
von Manage ihr Praktikum absolviert.
Grüessech. Gwennaëlle Menoud,
Notfalltierärztin.
Sie können gleich mitkommen.
In einem Jahr will sie sich auf die
neuen Haustierarten spezialisieren.
Im Wartzimmer: Leute mit Vögeln,
Hamstern und anderen Kleintieren.
Vanessa und ihre Tochter Emma warten,
bis sie an der Reihe sind.
Ich bin heute morgen mit meiner
elfjährigen Tochter gekommen.
Wir haben ein schwarzes Seidenhuhn,
das sechs Monate alt ist.
Den Namen Wizzi hat es
wegen unserem Nachbardorf Wizzi.
Ich wollte v.a. wegen den Eiern
eigene Hühner.
Wir haben immer frische Eier.
Das ist korrekter und auch gesunder.
Wizzi hat
einen tollpatschigen Charakter.
Sie rennt immer hinterher,
aber sie ist lustig.
Dank Emma merkte die Familie,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Sie kam mit dem Huhn in die Küche
und sagte,
es habe einen Knollen an der Backe.
Der Knollen könnte ein Tumor sein.
Vanessa und ihre Familie
befürchten das Schlimmste
und warten ungeduldig
auf die Tierärztin.
Ich komme zu Wizzi.
Grüessch, Dr. Menoud. Notfall-
tierärztin. Darf ich Sie bitten?
Soll ich sie hierher stellen?
Ja, ich lege noch etwas darunter.
Oh. Hoi, du.
Flauschig.
Das passt Wizzi gar nicht,
aber Emma versucht, sie zu beruhigen.
Langsam, langsam.
Mit dem Haarbüschel auf dem Kopf
sieht man nichts.
Ich staune,
dass Sie es gesehen haben.
Ich glaube, es wird immer grösser.
- Grösser und grösser?
In zwei Tagen
ist es viel grösser geworden.
Sie hatte auf den Backen
in Höhe der Ohren Auswüchse.
Auf dieser Seite ist es ...
- Ja, wirklich.
Nicht nur die Tochter
macht sich Sorgen.
Wir merkten, wie wir an ihr hängen.
Wir überlegten, was wir machen,
wenn wir sie töten müssen.
Hat sie keine Gleichgewichts-
störungen oder Ähnliches?
Nein, ich finde, das Verhalten
hat sich nicht verändert.- Ja, ja.
Ich tippe auf einen Abszess.
Aber es ist komisch,
dass es auf beiden Seiten ist.
Auch wenn es ein Tumor wäre,
auf beiden Seiten ...
Ein Tumor in dem Alter?
Man kann es nie ausschliessen.
Ein Tumor, Abszess.
Wizzi ist zu jung für einen Tumor.
Gwennaëlle hat eine andere Erklärung.
Es könnte
auch eine Ohrenentzündung sein.
Das wäre beidseitig
und das könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Das steht so raus?
- Ja, das kann es geben.
Dann sind das die Ohren?
- Ja, genau.
Das sind die Ohren. Ich wusste
nicht, wo ein Huhn Ohren hat.
Hühner haben keine Zähne, dafür aber
Ohren, die sich entzünden können.
Es ist eine Ohrenentzündung.
Darum fliesst Eiter aus den Ohren.
Wir müssen es hier behalten
und das chirurgisch ...
Auskratzen?
- ... am Ohr behandeln.
Ich habe ihnen erklärt,
dass wir eine Narkose machen
und dann den Abszess von aussen
herausschaben müssen.
Sollte es wiederkommen,
also sich wieder entzünden,
würden wir einen Scan machen
und das Ganze genauer anschauen.
Wizzi muss für den Eingriff
dableiben.
Sie können sie in den Korb legen.
Ich schaue, ob er kurz Zeit hat.
Ihr Huhn alleine zurückzulassen,
ist nicht einfach.
Ich komme gleich wieder.
- Okay.
Wir haben die Hühner
seit Mitte Juni.
Wir haben sie ins Herz geschlossen.
Hoffentlich kommt alles gut.
Wir machen auf jeden Fall,
was es braucht.
Ich hoffe trotzdem
auf gute Nachrichten.
Während Emma ihrer Wizzi
noch einmal Mut macht,
schaut William, wie es Sina
im Berner Tierspital geht.
Wie sieht es aus
mit der Transfusion?
Der Berner Sennenhund
leidet an Blutmangel.
Er hat schon
zwei Transfusionen erhalten
und die Spitalreserven
sind bald leer.
Ein wenig braucht sie.
- Hey, salut.
Hallo.
* Sina keucht.*
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik *
Ich bringe Alaska,
Alieska, Barinia und Bania.
Die vier Schlittenhunde
sind in Hochform und kerngesund.
Murielle hat auf den Aufruf
des Tierspitals reagiert
und bringt ihre vier Hunde
zur Blutspende.
Ich habe einen Anruf erhalten
und sie sagten mir,
es hätte
einen schweren Unfall gegeben,
bei dem sie viel Blut brauchten
und es wäre gut,
wenn ich kommen konnte.
... und Barinia.
Bei Tieren spenden weniger
als bei Menschen.
Wir haben ständig
zu wenig Blutkonserven.
Wir sind wahnsinnig froh um Leute,
die uns ihre Tiere, meistens Hunde,
zur Blutspunde bringen.
Wir freuen uns über alle,
die sich spontan melden.
Blut brauchen wir wirklich immer.
Murielle und ihre Hunde
waren vier Wochen in Finnland.
Sie machten
an einem Schlittenrennen mit.
Die Hunde sind so trainiert,
dass man vor lauter Muskeln
die Venen nicht findet.
Die leitendete Ärztin Katja
muss den Assistentinnen helfen.
Sie ist so muskulös,
sie spürt fast nichts.
Salut.
- Das sind nur Muskeln.
Mal sehen, ob Katja die Vene findet
und ob Barinia
noch so lange ruhig bleibt.
Was macht sie denn da?
(Flüsternd) Was machen die denn da?
Die suchen deine Vene.
Das war ein Zufallstreffer.
Endlich klappt es und
der Blutbeutel füllt sich langsam,
wenn sich Barinia
weiter still verhält.
(Säuselnd) Nein, nein, nein.
Neues Blut für Sina
und ein paar extra Streicheleinheiten
für die Spenderin.
Hey, das Warten hat sich gelohnt.
Wir möchten nicht, dass der Hund
ein negatives Erlebnis hat.
Wir möchten, dass er das
mit etwas Positivem verbindet.
Er kriegt etwas zu Essen,
er soll sich freuen.
Zwischendurch
nehmen wir ihm etwas Blut ab.
Jetzt gibt es die Belohnung
für Bania und Barinia.
Und Murielle
erhält vier Säcke Hundefutter.
Mit dem kleinen Geschenk
bedankt sich das Spital bei ihr.
Ganz ruhig,
es nimmt dir keiner etwas weg.
Es ist ein schöner Nebeneffekt, aber
ich mache es nicht aus dem Grund.
Ich finde es eine gute Sache.
Wir Menschen spenden auch Blut
für andere Menschen.
Ich wäre sicher auch froh,
dass Blut vorhanden ist,
wenn mein Tier Blut brauchen würde.
Dank Murielles Hunden hat Sina
noch mehr Transfusionen erhalten
und kann jetzt sogar aufstehen.
Das ganze Team ist so froh.
So ein Blutnachschub
ist für das Tier
wie ein Energy Drink für uns.
Dann haben sie mehr Energie.
William freut sich für Sina, aber
leider dauert die Freude nicht lange.
Der Hund hat Leukämie, was bei
Berner Sennenhunden häufig vorkommt.
Trotz der intensiven Pflege
für Sina -
die liebe, grosse Hündin stirbt noch
im Spital an einem Herzstillstand.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
In der Tierklinik im belgischen
Manage treffen wir wieder Wizzi,
das Huhn mit der Ohrentzündung.
Es kommt nun auf den Operationstisch.
Gwennaëlle
überlässt die Untersuchung David,
der schon Erfahrung
mit neuartigen Haustieren hat.
Also, wollen wir?
Brauchst du etwas Licht
oder geht es so?
Sogar der Facharzt hat Mühe, sich
in den vielen Federn zurechtzufinden.
Die Frage ist, ob es eine externe
Ohrentzündung ist, nur im Gehörgang,
oder ob sie schon im Mittelohr ist.
- Ja.
Wenn auch das Mittelohr
entzündet ist,
ist ein komplizierterer Eingriff
nötig,
der selbst Wizzis Leben
gefährden könnte.
Wir schauen zuerst,
wie sie es aushält.
Die Schmerzen?
- Ja, genau.
Ja, schon gut.
Das war ein Pfropfen.
Jetzt betäuben wir sie.
Mit der Kurzbetäubung?
- Einfach kurz.
Wizzi wird mit Gas betäubt.
Jetzt kann das Team
die Ohren säubern.
Holt man den Eiter nicht ganz raus,
wird die Entzündung immer grösser.
Bei Vögeln
muss man alles gut auskratzen,
damit es keine Abszesse mehr gibt.
Es ist so verhärtet,
da hätte alles Antibiotika der Welt
nicht mehr genützt.
Ich habe noch nie eine Ohrentzündung
bei einem Huhn behandelt.
aber der Vorgang ist ähnlich
wie bei anderen Tieren.
Wir wenden das, was wir gemeinsam
wissen, in der Behandlung an.
Das Auskratzen dauert ziemlich lange,
aber dann:
So, Schätzchen.
Es ist doch viel besser so.
Wizzi kann wieder
zurück zu ihrer Familie,
die schon seit einer Weile
im Wartezimmer sitzt.
* Beschwingte Streicherklänge *
Die Operation ist gut gegangen.
Wir konnten alles entfernen.
Sie können einmal schauen,
wie die Gehöröffnung jetzt aussieht.
Da sind alles kleine ...
* Verschiedene Igitt-Geräusche *
Bei den Hühnern
ist das Ohr eigentlich ein Loch.
Normalerweise sind Federn darüber.
- Ja, genau.
Mein Bruder meinte, ich spinne,
es sei ja nur ein Huhn.
Aber wenn man ein Tier hat,
über nimmt man
die ganze Verantwortung, oder?
Emma ist noch sehr aufgewühlt.
Sie kann es kaum glauben,
dass ihr Huhn wieder nach Hause kann.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Im Tierspital Bern
ist der Teufel los.
Ein paar Tiere
sind gleichzeitig gekommen.
William und seine Chefin Katja
versuchen, Prioritäten zu setzen.
Der junge Assistenzarzt
im Notfalldienst muss erkennen,
welches die dringendsten Fälle sind.
- Danke schön. Tipptopp.
Und schon kommt ein weiterer Notfall.
Das ist ein American Bully.
Er heisst Tyson,
genau so wie Mike Tyson.
Ich dachte, er hat die gleiche Farbe
und er ist auch so muskulös.
Darum nannte ich ihn Tyson.
Tyson ist von einem Tierarzt
in Lausanne geschickt worden.
Er hat etwas verschluckt,
das tödlich sein könnte.
Er hat aufgehört zu Fressen
und nur noch wenig getrunken.
Dass er gar nichts mehr frisst,
macht mir Angst.
Du bist aber mager.- Man sieht,
dass es ihm schlecht geht.
Sein Allgemeinzustand
ist sehr schlecht.
Bei einem gesunden Hund
sollte man die Rippen spüren,
wenn man mit der Hand darüber fährt,
aber man sollte sie nicht zählen
und erst recht nicht sehen können.
Der Bericht des Tierarztes
aus Lausanne ist bedenklich.
Tyson hat einen scharfen Gegenstand
verschluckt,
der wohl den Darm aufgerissen hat.
Sollte der Darminhalt
in den Bauchraum fliessen,
könnte Tyson
an einer Allgemeininfektion sterben.
William und seine Chefin Katja
beschliessen das weitere Vorgehen.
Hat er Knochen aufgenommen?
Er hat schon einen Teil erbrochen.
Haben sie ihn mit Knochen gefüttert?
- Sie haben ihm das gegeben.
Getrunken hat er nichts?
- Ich sehe nichts.- Kein Wasser?
Aber gegessen hat er.
Wir machen ein Röntgenbild
vom Abdomen in zwei Ebenen.
Hast du Blut ...
- Noch nicht abgeschickt.
Ich rede noch mit der Besitzerin.
Tyson muss sofort geröntgt werden.
William versucht herauszufinden,
was er verschluckt haben könnte.
So, also, Sie haben ihm
nie Knochen zum Fressen gegeben?
Letztes Mal bekam er
ein Schweinefüsschen.
Da waren Knochen drin,
aber sonst nichts dergleichen. Nein.
Ich wollte ihm mal
einen besonderen Leckerbissen geben.
Das sind Knochen, sonst weiss ich
nicht, was es sein kann.
Wenn wir das sehen ... Für uns
könnte es der Fremdkörper sein.
Viele Leute denken, einem Hund
müsse man einen Knochen geben.
Das stimmt schon,
aber einen ganzen Knochen
kann er auch ganz schlucken.
Dann bleibt er evtl. im Darm
oder im Magen stecken.
Das ist dann ein Problem.
Sie haben freie Hand.
Machen Sie, was Sie machen müssen.
Er muss operiert werden -
und das kostet.
Die Kosten belaufen sich
zwischen 2'000 und 2'500 Fr.
Damit hat Lindsey nicht gerechnet.
Wie soll sie ihren Hund retten,
wenn auf ihrem Konto
nur noch 600 Fr. sind,
die bis Ende Monat reichen müssen?
Kann man das abzahlen?
Ja, wir brauchen heute
eine Anzahlung von 750 Fr.
Ich habe nur 600 auf dem Konto.
Ich kann einfach nicht mehr.
Das verstehe ich.
Wir schicken die Rechnung
nach Hause. Dann können Sie anrufen.
Das ist perfekt so. Heute
kann ich es nicht hier bezahlen.
Perfekt.
- Gut. Ich rufe Sie an.
Vielen Dank.
- Adieu.
Die Radiologen
haben den Fremdkörper entdeckt,
der in Tysons Darm
steckengeblieben ist.
Etwas Scharfes, das eindeutig
den Darm eingerissen hat.
William muss sofort
eine Notoperation organisieren.
Es ist höchste Zeit.
Wir organisieren die OP
und den Chirurgen.
Es ist später Nachmittag. Das ganze
Team wird in den OP-Saal aufgeboten.
Der Chirurg, ein Assistent
und der Narkosearzt Matthieu.
Oh, là, là.
Dir geht es gar nicht gut.
Oje, das ist nicht lustig, Tyson.
Uh!
Oje, oje, aber du bist tapfer.
Verdacht auf einen Fremdkörper.
Der Zustand des Hundes
ist sehr lethargisch.
Der Allgemeinzustand
ist stark reduziert.
Herz-Kreislauf
bis jetzt noch stabil.
Ausgeflossene Flüssigkeit
im Bauchraum.
Deswegen Verdacht auf Perforation.
Es ist seltsam, dass ich nun
nach Lausanne zurückfahren soll
und mein Hund
ist ganz allein in Bern.
Vielleicht braucht er mich trotzdem.
Oje, du kleiner Kerl,
das ist nicht lustig.
Er ist mein kleiner Hund.
In der Zeit, als ich alleine war,
war er meine Stütze.
Er ist wie kleines Kind für mich.
Jetzt geht es an die OP.
* Düstere Klänge *
Wie heisst er?
Vorsichtig holt die Chirurgin Elisa
den Darm aus dem Bauchraum heraus,
damit sie den Schweinefuss
finden kann, der drin feststeckt.
Dann sieht es plötzlich
gar nicht mehr gut aus.
Der Darm ist schon ganz blau. Das
OP-Team befürchtet das Schlimmste.
Plötzlich habe ich realisiert,
dass der Darm eine blaue Farbe
angenommen hat.
Ich bekam Angst. Ist der Darm
schon so schlecht durchblutet,
kann der Hund sterben.
In dem Moment hatte ich Angst
und musste sofort etwas unternehmen.
Elisa muss sofort handeln.
Sie beschliesst,
den ganzen Darm total zu entleeren.
Das macht man normalerweise nicht
und es riecht sehr unangenehm.
Es ist die einzige Chance,
Tysons Leben zu retten.
* Wiederholtes Piepsen *
* Husten *
Vor der Tierpraxis Ajovet im Jura
wartet ein ungewöhnlicher Patient
auf Eléonore.
Er heisst Gaby.
Ich habe sie letztes Jahr zu meinem
25. Geburtstag geschenkt erhalten.
Es sind liebe Tiere
und sie haben sich an uns gewöhnt.
Manchmal gehe ich mit ihnen
spazieren. Es sind super Tiere.
Gaby ist ein junges Alpaka
und lebt mit seiner Schwester
im selben Gehege.
Damit sie keine Jungen machen,
muss Gaby kastriert werden.
Das hat Eléonore noch nie gemacht.
Sicher, im ersten Moment dachte ich:
"Das habe ich noch nie gemacht."
Andererseits muss man sich
auch an neue Sachen heranwagen.
Der neuen Sache
ist es gar nicht wohl im Anhänger.
Er sucht sicher sein Schwesterchen.
Sie sind noch nie allein gewesen.
Er ist es sich nicht gewohnt,
alleine zu sein.
Eléonore bleibt auf Distanz.
Sie weiss, dass Alpakas
ziemlich unberechenbar sind.
Als ich noch an der Uni war, musste
ich mich um ein Alpaka kümmern.
Das Tier hat beschlossen,
dass es mich nicht mag.
Ich konnte nicht in seine Nähe.
Alle konnten zu ihm, nur ich nicht.
Eléonore geht auf die Seite.
Sie will nicht bespuckt werden.
Sie vermischen vorverdautes Futter
und Magensaft aus dem Pansen
und sprayen es dann auf ihre Feinde.
Eléonores Chefin stülpt einen
Stoffsack über den Kopf von Gaby.
Bei gewissen Tieren
wirkt Dunkelheit beruhigend.
Auch Nicole
ist bei der Sache nicht ganz wohl.
Mit Alpakas
hatte sie noch nie zu tun.
* Lockere Musik *
Gaby, komm.
Sie ist gerutscht.
So, ja.
- Am besten noch etwas nach hinten.
Komm, komm.
Wir sind solche Tiere nicht gewohnt.
Wir wissen nicht ganz genau,
wie man bei der Narkose vorgeht.
Wir haben im Voraus etwas studiert
und in unseren Büchern nachgelesen,
wie es geht.
Am Schwierigsten ist die Narkose.
Das Tier auf die Waage zu bringen,
kann Eléonore vergessen.
Sie muss sein Gewicht
möglichst genau abschätzen,
weil eine Überdosis
fatale Folgen haben könnte.
Der Besitzer sagte,
es sei 50 kg schwer.
Als ich es das erste Mal sah, dachte
sich, es sei doch viel schwerer.
Beim Anfassen wurde mir klar,
dass da viel Wolle dran ist.
Eléonore geht von 50 kg aus.
Damit sie das völlig verängstigte
Tier nicht noch mehr stressen muss,
gibt sie ihm die Spritze
schon auf dem Parkplatz.
Endlich schläft Gaby ein.
Jetzt können wir ihn reintragen. Wir
brauchen eine Trage. Haben wir eine?
Er ist ja gar nicht schwer.
Das ist ja nur Wolle.
Achtung.
Beim Tragen merkten wir,
dass er nicht so schwer sein kann,
wie er aussieht,
vielleicht weniger als 50 kg.
Achtung, zuerst den Kopf.
So.
Wenn wir ihn so hinlegen,
fällt der Hals runter.
So geht es besser.
Der OP-Tisch
ist beinahe etwas zu klein.
Der Kopf ist immer noch unten.
Da, ja.
Nicoles Mann muss kommen,
um den Kopf hochzuhalten.
Es war super,
dass jemand den Kopf gehalten hat,
er hätte sich wehtun können.
In der Narkose beugen die Tiere
oft den Hals nach hinten.
Das wäre gefährlich in der Position.
Jetzt ist alles bereit
für die Operation.
Die sind ja klein!
Ja. Du musst sie mit den Fingern
zusammendrücken,
um einen klaren Schnitt
in die Hoden zu machen.
Ich versuchte es mit der Technik,
die man bei Hunden anwendet.
Es ist ganz zart,
schlimmer als bei einem Hund.
Der erste Teil des Eingriffs
ist gut gegangen,
aber als es darum geht,
die Hoden zu unterbinden ...
Woher kommt das Blut?
Ah, das ist die Haut, die blutet.
Eléonores Technik funktioniert nicht.
Der Faden hat sich gelöst,
die Wunde beginnt zu bluten.
Das Fett ist gerissen. Meine Naht
ist auseinandergefallen.
Es hat sich gelöst - darum das Blut.
Die OP dauert länger als vorgesehen.
Die Wirkung der Narkose lässt nach,
was gefährlich werden könnte.
Man muss sehr aufpassen,
sie machen schnelle Bewegungen.
Ein Hufschlag kann schmerzen.
Nicole verlängert die Narkose,
damit Eléonore mit der Operation
weitermachen kann.
Ich habe das ganze Paket unterbunden
und es gab keine Probleme mehr.
Die hast du gepackt.
- Merci.
Eléonore ist ins Schwitzen geraten,
aber jetzt ist alles gut.
Noch ein Pflaster - und Gaby kann
in seinen Anhänger gebracht werden.
Dieses Mal
läuft alles wie am Schnürchen.
Zumindest beinahe.
Das gibt es ja nicht.
Gaby erwacht langsam und kann bald
wieder mit seiner Schwester spielen.
* Lockere Musik *
Wir haben beide noch einmal kontrol-
liert, ob er gut erwacht ist.
Es war alles bestens.
Eine Erleichterung
auch für den Tierarzt.
Das ist ein neuer Gaby,
der auf seine Schwester zugeht.
Auch Quentin ist glücklich.
Ich bin froh,
sind die beiden wieder zusammen.
Ich hatte schon etwas Angst,
man weiss ja nie.
Es sind schon spezielle Tiere.
Sie sind sehr anhänglich
und haben eine besonderen Charakter.
Ich freue mich auf das Nächste.
* Lockere Musik *
In Bern ist es spät geworden.
Die Chirurgen
behandeln immer noch Tysons Darm.
Elisa musste
ein Stück davon herausschneiden,
damit sie den Schweinefuss entfernen
konnte, der darin blockiert war.
Es sieht gut aus für Tyson.
William hat inzwischen Feierabend.
Er schaut noch einmal,
wie es seinem Patienten geht.
Da schaut ihr noch.
Es war die rechte Entscheidung,
ihn sofort zu operieren.
Er war ein Kandidat, bei dem es
Komplikationen hätte geben können,
wenn wir bis am Morgen
gewartet hätten
und erst dann geschaut,
wie es weitergeht.
Tysons Darm hat es überstanden.
Die Operation ist fertig.
Nach 2 Std. höchster Konzentration
kann Elisa endlich aufatmen.
Wenn ich denke, wie es zu Beginn
aussah, als der Darm blau wurde,
bin ich froh,
konnten wir das Problem lösen.
Jetzt schauen wir, wie es sich in
den nächsten fünf Tagen entwickelt,
ob der Darm gut heilt.
Im Moment ist nichts sicher.
Für Tyson ist es noch nicht zu Ende.
Der Schweinefuss hinterliess Schäden.
Die Überraschung kommt
bei der Reinigung des Fremdkörpers.
Es ist ein Stein.
Einen Schweinefuss konnte ich
mir nur schwer vorstellen.
Normalerweise verdauen sie ihn.
Nein, es ist ein Stein.
Ein grosser Stein,
den Tyson beinahe das Leben kostete.
Er kommt jetzt
auf die Intensivstation.
Dort bleibt er über Nacht.
In der belgischen Tierklinik,
in der Gwennaëlle arbeitet,
kommen laufend neue Notfälle.
Der nächste Patient
sitzt auf Fabians Schulter.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Ich bin Alessia. Ich bin
18 Jahre alt. Das ist mein Vater.
Wir sind mit Ratatouille
hierhergekommen, knapp zweijährig.
Sie ähnelt wirklich Ratatouille
aus dem Animationsfilm.
Sie schmust gern,
ist herzig und anhänglich.
Es ist eine richtig liebe Ratte.
Sie ist einfach als Haustier zu
halten. Nicht wie ein Hund oder so.
Grüessech.
Menoud, Notfallveterinärin.
Sie können gleicht mit mir kommen.
Ich mache mir Sorgen,
weil sie am Hals einen Klumpen hat.
Alessia hat nicht lange gewartet und
ist sofort in die Klinik gekommen.
Ratatouille ist eine Farbratte.
Das sind neugierige, lebhafte
und intelligente Haustiere.
Gesundheitlich
sind sie ziemlich anfällig.
Sie werden
nur zwei bis drei Jahre alt.
Der Klumpen am Hals
könnte etwas Schlimmes sein.
Wann haben Sie es gemerkt?
Ich habe gleich angerufen,
als ich es gesehen habe.
Wir untersuchen sie rasch.
Komm, Ratatouille.
Hoppla.
Wurde sie schon einmal gewogen?
Wenn wir sagen,
wir hätten eine Farbratte,
finden die Leute das eklig
und reden von Krankheiten.
Es ist ein Haustier,
das Körner frisst.
Es sind wirklich
ganz herzige Tierchen.
Sehr anhänglich, ganz lieb.
Trotz der Vorurteile,
die die Leute haben.
Es ist erstaunlich.
- Stimmt.
Das Herz ist in Ordnung,
auch wenn es im Moment stark pocht.
Gwennaëlle untersucht den Klumpen,
der Alessia Sorgen bereitet.
Schmerzen bereitet er
offensichtlich keine.
Der Auswuchs
kann mehrere Gründe haben.
Eine solche Wucherung
kann ein Tumor sein.
Oder eine Entzündung
der Speicheldrüse.
Es gibt ein paar Möglichkeiten.
Man kann nicht sofort eine Diagnose
stellen. Es sind Vermutungen.
Wir haben die Speicheldrüse
und die Lymphknoten.
Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Aber Gwenaëlle entdeckt noch mehr.
Ich spüre Auswüchse links am Bauch.
Ist Ihnen das schon aufgefallen?
Weitere Auswüchse -
das hätten sie nicht erwartet.
Die Tierärztin hat noch andere
Klumpen an der Brust gesehen.
Ob es einen Zusammenhang gibt?
- Genau deshalb warten wir,
was sie sagt.
Es wäre traurig,
wenn es etwas Schlimmes wäre.
Besser, wir bereiten uns
auf das Schlimmste vor.
Sie ist schon bald zwei Jahre alt.
Eine kleine Untersuchung ist gut.
Wir drücken heute Abend die Daumen.
Mit einem Ultraschall sehen wir,
woher der Auswuchs kommt.
Die kleinen Auswüchse am ganzen
Körper sind nicht so harmlos.
Alessia hat Mühe,
sich von Ratatouille zu trennen.
Aber es bleibt ihr
nichts anderes übrig.
Es braucht
eine Ultraschalldiagnostik.
Ich brauche noch
ein paar Informationen.
Das ist Ratatouille.
Bald zwei Jahre alt
und 500 g schwer.
Der Tierarzt schaut zuerst die
kleinen Auswüchse an der Brust an.
Sie kommen oft bei Ratten vor
und es ist tatsächlich ein Tumor,
aber ein gutartiger.
Jetzt untersucht er
den grossen Knoten am Hals.
Siehst du,
das ist der grosse Knoten.
Du siehst, er ist abgekapselt
und nicht durchblutet.
D.h., dass es ziemlich sicher
ein Abszess ist.
Er ist recht gross.
Ratatouilles Halter werden sich
freuen, dass es kein Krebs ist,
aber der Abszess muss weg.
Die Auswüchse an der Brust
sind nicht lebensbedrohlich,
der Abszess schon.
Er kann sich weiter ausbreiten
und Entzündungen auslösen,
die für die Gefässe rund um den Hals
gefährlich werden können.
Also wird operiert.
Drei Leute bemühen sich
um das kleine Tier.
Wir stechen den Abszess gemeinsam
auf, du machst dann die Drainage.
Weil es so klein ist, muss jeder
Handgriff an dem Tier sitzen.
damit es am Leben bleibt.
Das Risiko bei Kleintieren ist viel
grösser als bei Hunden oder Katzen.
Genau das gefällt mir
an der Spezialisierung.
Also, los geht's.
David versucht,
den Abszess ganz herauszunehmen.
Ein höchst riskanter Eingriff, weil
daneben lebenswichtige Arterien sind.
Ich gehe schrittweise vor,
um nichts falsch zu machen.
* Spannende Musik, Piepsen *
Jetzt sehe ich den Schädel
und einen Teil des Knochens.
Gwenaëlle schaut, wie es
ihrem kleinen Patienten geht.
Wir haben eine
bakterielle Infektion.- Alles klar.
Die Operation ist bestens verlaufen
und Ratatouille
geht es schon wieder blendend.
Jetzt kann Gwenaëlle Alessia anrufen.
Ich rufe wegen Ratatouille an.
Sie können Sie am Abend holen.
Ja, gern, wenn es Ihnen passt.
Fabian, Alessias Vater,
holt Ratatouille ab.
Das Tierchen war nur einen Tag in der
Klinik und fehlt der ganzen Familie.
Sie war das erste Mal allein,
ohne uns.
Es war komisch.
Etwas hat im Haus gefehlt.
Ich zeige es gleich.
Es ist auf dieser Seite.
Sie müssen sie nun
weiterhin pflegen.
Da unten müssen sie einsalben.
Heute Abend sitzt wieder die ganze
Familie am Tisch, auch Ratatouille.
Danke und einen guten Abend.
- Danke.- Sehr gern.
Gwennaëlle kommt nicht zur Ruhe.
Sie kommen mit einem Frettchen?
- Ja, genau.
Sehr erfreut, Dr. Menoud, Notärztin.
- Grüessech.
Die hier gesammelten Erfahrungen
sind sehr wertvoll
für die junge Tierärztin,
die sich auf neue Haustierarten
und wild lebende Tiere
spezialisieren will.
Nach dem einjährigen Praktikum in
Belgien will sie in Kanada arbeiten
und vielleicht irgendwann
in der Schweiz
ein Zentrum
für wild lebende Tiere eröffnen.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
In Bern geht William zum letzten Mal
zu seinem Patienten Tyson.
Der American Bully hatte
einen grossen Stein verschluckt.
Nach der schweren OP und
einem zehntägigen Spitalaufenthalt
kann er heute nach Hause.
Seiner Besitzerin Lindsey
hat er wahnsinnig gefehlt.
Er war zehn Tage im Spital
und das war sehr lange
Ich musste viel an ihn denken.
Mein Hündchen hat mir gefehlt,
es war komisch ohne ihn.
Hey, Schätzchen!
Oh, ich liebe dich.
Tyson sieht
noch etwas mitgenommen aus.
Er hat in zwei Wochen
7 kg abgenommen.
* Ein Hund bellt. *
(Lachend) Ein Riesenkopf
auf dem kleinen Körper.
Und der Stein? Wie gross war er?
- Etwa so.
Also recht gross.
Er zwar ziemlich flach und breit,
darum blieb er stecken.
Lindsay kann es kaum glauben. Jetzt
muss sie Tyson ständig überwachen,
damit er keine Steine mehr frisst.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass er etwas gelernt hat.
Ein Hund kann den Zusammenhang
nicht wirklich verstehen,
Aber die Besitzer und Besitzerinnen
haben es verstanden,
haben etwas gelernt
und passen künftig gut auf.
In den nächsten Tagen gibt es für
Tyson nur Reis, Poulet und Käse.
Ich schmuse mit ihm und ich
bereite ihm seine Spezialmenüs zu.
Ich nehme mir Zeit für ihn
und für mich, für uns gemeinsam.
Lindsay hat
eine 8 m lange Leine gekauft,
damit sie ihrem Hund die komische
Vorliebe für Steine abgewöhnen kann.
Nach seinem Praktikum
auf der Notfallstation
hat William noch
auf anderen Abteilungen gearbeitet.
Er möchte Tierchirurg werden.
Darum hat er sich für
ein Praktikum in den USA beworben,
als Assistent
in einer Chirurgie-Abteilung.
* Heitere Musik *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Drollige Klänge *
Im Jura wird es langsam dunkel,
aber Eléonore
hat noch nicht Feierabend.
Es ist ein harter Beruf,
das ist klar.
V.a. als Landtierarzt
muss man Tag und Nacht,
sieben Tage die Woche,
das ganze Jahr einsatzbereit sein.
* Ächzen *
Heute Abend ist sie bei Fernand.
Er hat Probleme mit einer Kuh,
die nach dem Kalbern
nicht mehr aufgestanden ist.
Providence ist total erschöpft.
Um 2 Uhr dachte ich,
es würde ihr besser gehen,
aber sie konnte
nicht mehr aufstehen.
Ist sie gar nie aufgestanden?
Sie hat es versucht, aber nein,
nur beinahe.
Weil sie seit heute Morgen
nichts mehr getrunken hat,
wird sie gedrencht, ihr wird
Wasser eingeflösst - mind. 40 l.
Sind Kühe dehydriert, kann es sein,
dass sie nicht mehr aufstehen.
Darum muss man ihr nachhelfen.
Eléonore mischt einen Kraftdrink,
um der Kuh
genügend Flüssigkeit zu geben.
Das passt dir nicht,
aber das muss sein.
Mach den Mund auf!
* Eléonore ächzt. *
Schluck runter!
Man steckt den Schlauch durch
die Speiseröhre bis in den Pansen.
Ich bleibe an den Zähnen hängen.
Ah, voilà.
40 l Wasser
werden direkt in den Magen gepumpt.
Gepumpt wird von Hand.
40 l klingen nach wahnsinnig viel,
aber so viel ist es nicht.
Der Pansen einer Kuh
fasst 200-250 l.
40 l sind das Mindeste, die es
für eine Wirkung überhaupt braucht.
Jetzt wird sich Providence
wieder erholen.
Eléonore hat immer
ein Lächeln bereit,
trotz der Müdigkeit,
trotz der Aufopferung.
Ich glaube, jeder Tierarzt, der sich
auf Grosstiere spezialisiert, weiss,
dass er sein Leben
den Tieren widmet.
Wir sehen das nicht als Aufopferung.
Wir wollen das machen.
Okay.
Wir lassen sie hier ausruhen.
In den zwei Jahren, in denen
Eléonore in Porrentruy arbeitet,
konnte sie das Vertrauen der Bauern
gewinnen.
Jetzt führt sie ihre Tierliebe nach
Estavayer-le-Lac am Neuenburgersee.
Da arbeitet sie weiter
als Landtierärztin -
mit Leidenschaft
und bis spät in die Nacht.
* Lockere Gitarrenmusik *
Auch nächste Woche geht es weiter
mit spannenden Tiergeschichten
bei "Tierärztin 24/7".
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020